m
[Musique]
les gentilles
r non on défend on tombe sur un virus
voilà
allez
la vierge
[Musique]
je regarde par ici
étrange
heureusement pour appâter
qui vont mal verrez ça me va me va bien
il est un peu long mais maintenant c'est
la mode c'est la même chanson
alors quand je mets de côté pour voir
shalit prochaine maintenant une fois ma
part je travaille à cécile thomas
remettre à lui bien là comme à chacun
raconte des mensonges et des comptes en
suisse a dit voilà qui ne sont payées
par là puis vous dire que pour lui voilà
la côte d'ivoire merci madame allure la
remercierai thiaroye de votre descente
alors ça jusqu'à votre dix prochains
madame oui les tremper des travaux
franchement c'est tout mais alors là
sociale
c'est ce qui vient de bien ma mère non
elle ne dit qu il fallait qu'elle parle
un peu yougoslave comme voit quand même
que les yougos elles ne sont pas venus
ici seulement pour travailler qui se
passe aussi à a
c'est vrai je ne sais pas s'ils
voulaient travailler au percement bon si
on n'applique pas y ait beaucoup de la
poker awards à santa maria au poteau 40e
on les connaît que vous ne connaissez
pas
non ça n'arrive pas
[Musique]
12e